we have played the call duty beta we
have a review for battle 31 is up we're
going to talk about that in the next
segment when Miguel comes on I was
review and titanfall to rob you and I
have played a lot can't couldn't you've
played a lot of preview yeah yeah L
Scott so let's talk about kind of there
were two shooters are three shooters are
in the air between battleborn doom and
overwatch but we kind of covered those
maybe at the end of you we're gonna do a
wrap-up like which was the best route of
the year or something I don't know but
right now we want to do like if you have
to get one shooter this fall which one
is for you not saying you have to you
can get all three that would be great
too because Infinity Ward dice and
respawn are all great developers and
I've had fun with all these games so far
um but I kind of want to touch them like
the differences i don't like I think
we're all probably gonna I don't know
that we're all gonna pick one
individually but we don't have to pick
one but I kind of discuss it for people
watching like which one's for you let's
just start with battlefield one because
it was the first in the release on the
21st Rob you are enjoying this game a
lot and I think a lot of people are yeah
i mean it's it's got kind of everything
I want and again having like grown up
with 1942 and being like obsessed with
that game like I was in a stupid-ass
clan we didn't win a single match in
that clan but I was obsessed with it and
this is exciting for me like I remember
when this was released or announced that
was gonna be World War one remember
being like oh I won World War two but
this is ultimately World War two I mean
it's got the heart and soul of that
original game you know seeing this game
take on different fronts different sides
different like outfits for each
corresponding location planes tanks like
it's the all-out war conflict that I
think I hold dear and have always liked
been obsessed with and I think they're
they're totally I think they also took
most of us by surprise where we were
talking about oh how are they going to
handle this world war one vibe like are
they going to be gentle with it and it
seems like what you know with like
operations that mode is really unique
how you kind of get a little bit of
heart and narrative whether or not you
lose or win that a battle it kind of
carries over into the next one you feel
like you made an impact like to come you
know to segue and combined more than one
match I think it's like a really
engaging thing and yeah just in general
like I love flying planes so it's it's
also there like this is battlefield as
opposed to any of the shooter but pedal
field i think is for more patient people
as far as like what you're going to be
playing right because there are
sometimes you're gonna be covering large
swaths of land and nothing's going to
happen it's about that lead up to the
battles and the violence and the
skirmishes but they're also these
moments where you're like kind of you're
sitting at this point this outpost
you're covering this like to defend it
like in case someone flanks and like you
might be scouting and you're not gonna
see anybody for ten minutes but you'll
still be doing something kind of vital
it's not going to be like this moment to
moment thing like Call of Duty or this
like fluid kind of like fast-paced thing
like titanfall but there are a lot more
situations when I feel like I'm part of
a bigger picture in battlefield whether
i'm actually just like shooting another
person or not or firing a weapon at all
and that's what i like about battlefield
and that's kind of like why I think
battlefield one's my favorite one in a
while because that happens more often
than it did with like four or hard LAN
or anything right and it's got such
different yet you kind of said different
varying levels of pace right like if you
are getting your ass handed to you on
the front lines hey there's a plane you
can hop into maybe you should take up
scout and hit the hills like that is a
nice break because if there's one thing
I would have to say about call duty
games like as much as I have loved in
the past but there is a moment where you
might be on a bad streak yeah and it's
like your heart can't handle it and I'm
just like I got to take a break I think
that's like the something that Mia
battlefield kind of does differently
yeah I don't know did you play a
battlefield much yet Scott your the
chance I'm a little bit of the
multiplayer I'm actually really excited
to try the campaign I like the way
they've structured of doing it sort of
like a series of nonlinear vignettes
sounds really cool to me but yeah I mean
I think you guys really really know you
know hit the nail on the head that it
multiplier seems to embrace what people
or what really distinguish battlefield
from other shooters in the past I mean
hardline and for two maybe a lesser
extent where I think trying to compete
very directly with what call of duty
does and be a little bit more like
moment to moment you know instant
gratification wit shooter and
battlefield one is very much back to ya
like
very much slower pacing more strategic
options vehicles larger Maps longer
modes all that kind of stuff that makes
it more strategic and gives it up just a
different overall feel compared to its
competitors sure um I don't know have
you played he got into trance playing
the infinite warfare like you play call
duties jug yearly uh I don't know about
yearly but I played pretty much all of
them since since modern warfare lucky of
the modern era i think i'm not sure i've
actually completely skipped any like I
played a bit ago so it was like nah and
David one ghost yeah but yeah like I
love the black ops trilogy I don't think
I ever actually played a lamb homes last
year's game it was an infinite warfare
was like ops 3 yeah okay with two years
ago the last vance were four badd
warfare like yeah i was a sledgehammer
games yes no I'm so I'm sorry second
mark 3 with Sly James first call right
the whole like three studio rotation
thing yet it's a little hard to ya track
cuz there's one every year but if an
affair like a lot to you I missed from
what I've seen a minute warfare
regardless i'm very excited i think it's
gonna be kind of different kind of cool
for call of duty and it is doing
something very different compared to
battlefield because it's sticking with
its you know instant gratification die
respawn over and over you know kill
death ratio pursuit kind of gameplay
yeah that call judy has really known for
and if you're if you're listening to us
on the podcast or earlier in the show
apologies for discussing infinite
warfare again but it does have the rigs
which are kind of like we said we're
borrowing from black ops 3 specialists
or like hero shooters or mobile just
these characters you can kind of get
used to which titanfall what you get
into in a second is also kind of doing
something with that but call duty like
the the big thing right now for me is
the campaign because i'm assuming it
will just be like call duty campaigns
are always like a nice break from the
multiplayer i do play call duty for the
multiplayer although the campaign's like
the black ops trilogy i totally agree
did really cool things their
storytelling yeah black ops 3 did some
really weird stuff i don't want to spoil
anything but if you played through that
whole campaign it got weird toward the
end and I actually kind of liked it for
as like I don't know kind of archaic or
sorry cryptic as some of it was but um
yeah call of duty obviously I think it
goes out saying there's not much to say
as far as like if you like last year's
call duty and you have a lot you got
like you press to use a few times you're
probably gonna like this one don't leave
for you like if you're just if you want
to sit down and play a match and you
know just if you're good at the like
reflexes and fast paced the twitchy kind
of game play and
the ridges are new but those ideas were
kinda already there the idea of these
very specialized classes I mean they've
been diving deeper and deeper into that
style for a long time so this is just
sort of like the next step the next
iteration right yeah but I think it
could be cool i like i like the space
setting I'm excited about the campaign I
I mean I I enjoy the campaign for the
same reason I watch like superhero
movies right and they're never gonna be
you know works of art but they're gonna
be like big and loud and fun I'm gonna
enjoy experiencing them for at least a
little bit yeah you plowed through it in
six hours and be like that was cool and
then just go play much multiplayer like
I know I always have fun with those
definitely um I think it was safe to do
that it was a good move you know like I
that is kind of the next progression
like I think I'm I'm very much over you
know the idea of the near future here on
earth like I like the idea of you know
like that's the next step like colonized
planets and seeing or being able to get
more creative and like showing and
experimenting with gravity and all that
stuff like I was a good direction sure
um to go on to like the third one there
was I want to like touch on Gears of War
for because it's not the same Sun
first-person shooter but as a shooter
and gears war kind of established pretty
much cover based third-person shooters
at least raise the bar back in two
thousand six or two thousand seven when
first released I reviewed it I gave it a
seven of ten i liked it think it's a
really good game i had some problems
with it but you know people hate me for
it but i really am i'm still in playing
horde mode I've been playing multiplayer
to horde mode is so good hormones really
good hosing the class base and like
again like it's not the same vein as
titanfall to call to the infinite
warfare or battlefield one it's not a
first-person shooter but it does have
his own flavor obviously like whether
it's the third person multiplayer that
again they kind of really like brought a
new watermark for back when it released
I remember the first one being a nice
break from like my halo system link in
the garage days and just doing like
those extremely intense 2v2 competitive
matches we're like it's the only you and
weather guy and you're just launching
sniper rifle shots like it's still got
that from what I've seen and hearing you
guys talk about that yeah like those are
good matches yeah horde mode totally
worth getting to Jake Decker and I've
still dabbling with it if I had more
time to play that I definitely would the
class-based five classes now if you have
all five people in each one of the
classes it's really fun and it's still
like I think it's better than three
use horde mode which I think they try to
do too much with it this they scaled
back where they needed to but they also
introduced cool things that like ed
really good wrinkles to the formula yeah
definitely agree and I think you you're
very right about competitive multiplayer
gears really does movement and
positioning in a way that no other
shooter really does like the tactics of
how you maneuver through the battlefield
is so unique to gears in a way that's
like kind of indescribable but like the
heft of the characters and like the
weight of cover and the way that you
employ cover it's not just about like oh
I'm gonna post up here and fire it's
like you're using cover almost as like
your s like you're charting a path
trying to get to your enemies more so
than like oh it's just it's part of the
shooting like it's really kind of its
own you have to think about it in its
own way in like a way that I'm not
articulating well right now no yeah
you're seeing like chess moves almost
yeah I don't know looking absolutely
okay let me jump over this cover and
like you know you know basically flank
someone what's the best way to get them
by surprise I wonder if like I I'm
pretty sure like when they first
released the first gear is that was
totally intentional like they wanted
people to take advantage that magnetism
but it took you a few hours to get used
to like you see people doing it like
people that were doing the flip with the
nasher like halfway through them cover
to cover oh my god that's possible i
didn't dashing yeah i didn't know you
could shoot that like halfway through
remember we played that legend last year
was that Oh Ultimate Edition there was
some guy who was like coming down a cord
or just sliding around it was its heart
gripping it was like oh yeah it's really
creepy spooky and then yeah like it I
don't know like that gears like still
still feels great it still is very much
Gears of War um they didn't do a ton of
new things with this but like I think
they did enough like it's well worth
going back to the series for sure you
did a great documentary on we do the
game swatch studios and you led that one
up on a kind of rod fergusson like it
wasn't t back in the day like the dad
issues the emotional core series the
other side of gears that isn't like the
chain saws and the blood and gore Jeff
because it's always been there like
there's always been that side of gears
which is has always struck me as very
odd considering the you know that the
other half of it is so violent and gory
and like over-the-top masculine chest
bump or whatever so it's it was always
so weird to me that those two things
existed within the same game and I just
decided to kind of dig into it and
fortunately for us Rob bergersen is like
really forthcoming with his answer
was really really generous with like
what he was willing to tell us about
that aspect of the game very well spoken
and uh like you know articulate guy for
sure um but yeah last one titanfall 2
that is releasing neck a week from
Friday I think it's this Friday snow
battlefield one and civ six or this
friday it's weird because we've had all
these ahead of time yeah so 20 yeah so
battlefield one and civilization six or
friday not the civil'zation six a
shooter and then titanfall is a week
after on the twenty-eighth okay right
yeah it's hard to keep track because we
played all of them at this point and
like even the public has like had early
access to like battlefield and then now
call duty on ps4 but titanfall 2 is that
last one we want to talk about and this
is the one I think a lot of people are
curious about because first was a great
game it felt awesome to established this
new kind of trend in shooters of
focusing on movement and like black ops
3 advanced warfare the call of duty's
kind of took over over watch some of the
characters like lucio can like wall run
and everything and whatnot Hanzo can
jump over involved but that's your real
grappling hook so many grappling hook
grappling hooks now there's a lot of
them this big thing titanfall 2
introduces one but you and I have played
a lot of it after the review event Scott
you've done so make sense of preview
covers on titanfall 2 and just like
leaving aside anything else despite how
much like Battlefield one despite how
like promising Call of Duty has been in
some respects I'm excited about
titanfall 2 because I got burned out in
the first one like a lot of people it
was always cranked up to 11 and I know
after we did a few feature videos on the
development team at respawned they said
one thing they want to do is kind of
tune it back in certain respects so it's
not always cranked up to 11 it sometimes
goes down to like five so you have these
calmer moments but and then it's that
lead up like that battlefield that
overwatch lead up to the action where
you're kind of planning things out and
then your plan is going to fall apart
and you're going to have to react to
that but also like you know I don't want
to focus too much on the Titans because
that's it's easy to do with titanfall 2
but right obviously it's that interplay
between pilots and Titans but also the
fact that Titans are more like heroes
now rather than these just two things
that you're going to like deck out with
similar loadouts is the next person like
you talk about how like scorcher Ronan
or North Star kind of like playing into
this new formula yeah I don't those
Titans are great I mean they're really
great but i would say for me at least
it's the mobility
um yeah I mean you said it like so many
games have kind of taken that path but
there is something about titan falls
especially they're like map layout of
like chaining your parkour moves in such
a manner where it just feels so
empowering I just yeah that game is for
me at least it's like the break from
battlefield I think those two are like
actually probably the most immersive as
far as that spectrum goes I get so
anxious kind of just like sprinting in
battlefield when I could just be like
grappling hook and wall running and
likes ground sliding in titanfall all
right back once you have those abilities
and other games it's like you squander
yeah because you start thinking about
maps and mobility in different ways like
you see some you know vantage point that
I can just grab no I can't this is
battlefield yeah but yeah titanfall to
like it's it's crazy from what we played
like Scott I think you were the first
one on gamespot to actually see all 6
Titans in action Rob and I had done
coverage when it was still just scorch
and I on hmm now all three of us have
played it with six Titans and I can I I
don't want to talk too much about it on
Myron from my perspective because i'm
reviewing it i'm kind of in the middle
to review right now but there's
definitely a feel that like not only do
you want to know that tightens so you
know how to use them but you also want
to see a North Star know how to counter
them you want to see an eye on and know
what not to do against an eye on and
like if you're a pilot how to take him
out but there's definitely much more of
like you said earlier like a chess game
vibe like you said with yours but like
even back at e3 when i interviewed vince
zampella he was saying like they were
almost inspired by fighting games which
you wouldn't think of because it's that
thing you want to know how to counter
all these characters but i don't know
what's your take on time fall to like
there are a lot of these minor additions
that are kind of you know they're trying
to set it apart from titanfall one but
you know ideally they like people to
keep playing do you think it has the
legs do you think I don't know do you
think like titanfall 2 is could be the
shooter the fall for a lot of people I
mean so the nice thing about titanfall
is I think it's positioning itself so
that doesn't have to be the shooter like
it's offering something a little bit
different in that it does have this
combination of the you know the high
mobility of pilots and then also like
the high durability of titans and like
having to earn Titans just the sort of
the flow of combat in the way that those
do things marry in any given match gives
it a very unique kind of pacing and feel
and strategy that I think it's just
going to be a matter of taste for most
people so in terms of does it have
enough legs I don't know I think it
definitely is going to have more
longevity enjoy more longevity than the
original titanfall I think it's made
some really smart changes that are going
to keep people invested for a longer
period of time the six titans being part
of that I mean and also having the
campaign I think we'll keep will endear
the game to gamers right I think more
people will want to hang on to the game
once they kind of have developed an
understanding of the universe and kind
of connect with the titans and and
hopefully that will actually impact sort
of the emotional connection even in
multiplayer um so we'll see who knows i
mean i i've really enjoyed all the time
I spent with the game I don't know that
it's going to you know dethrone
battlefield especially now that we know
that it's as good as it is but I could
totally see myself enjoying both and
wanting to take a break from one and
play the other because they offer such
different things yeah absolutely I mean
like I was like you know and just
touching on what you said even the fact
that it is a good move that they've
really characterized these Titans
because I'm almost fairly certain to be
honest like that there will be a 7th
tighten down the road right like that
there will be that reason to come back
and check it out even if it is for a few
hours but i think that's that's like a
neat idea yeah yeah no I mean like we
can talk about all we want the like at
the very least this year has been
awesome for shooters you had like
battleborn overwatch di bus Diablo doom
from earlier in the year in each melon
yeah and now you have these are these
for you if gears were for as a
third-person shooter but in terms of
first person you have battlefield one
titanfall to call to the infinite
warfare all of which the ones we haven't
officially reviewed still seems somewhat
promising in a lot of respects so yeah
that is the shooters releasing this fall
so which one you think is for you
titanfall 2 gears war for call duty
infinite warfare or battlefield 1 let us
know in the comments below